there is going to be a staggering amount
of disinformation spread around the 2020
election this includes the primary this
includes the general election once we
have a Democratic presidential nominee
now I do my best to point out specific
instances of disinformation and try to
debunk them on the show so for example
yesterday on the show we looked at this
sort of meme spread by James Woods and
Charlie Kirk and others about Bernie
Sanders and his tax plan and his health
care plan but we can't rely on debunking
zin media because we simply can't keep
up I mean it takes five seconds to tweet
out disinformation and then it took me
10 minutes to debunk it for you and
explain to you all the ways in which it
was wrong and the way Bernie's tax plan
will actually work so we all need
strategies to protect ourselves from the
disinformation instead of hoping that
you come across someone else debunking
disinformation there's a new report from
Stanford which says that we're gonna see
a lot of the same techniques from 2016
used spread disinformation in 2020 plus
there will be new more sophisticated
techniques that have surfaced over the
last four years and they prey on
visceral emotional reactions that is one
of the main ways that this information
spreads which is you see something and
you're your emotional reaction makes you
immediately share it before you've
actually vetted what it is that you were
sharing so the acronym to remember is
caps you know like Trump uses caps lock
during a lot of his tweets caps is the
acronym I used this when I was teaching
at Boston College in the media literacy
section of the class and what this means
is critically analyze primary sources
caps critically analyze primary sources
it's extremely simple but it is pretty
all-encompassing if you apply it
correctly you only need to ask two
questions whenever you're presented with
any claim in media am I looking at a
primary source and have I critically
analyzed it
so as an example if we look at that
viral disinformation tweet from
yesterday that
spread by James Woods and Charlie Kirk
and other right-wingers so first of all
we look through it and look at is
anything here a primary source so when
the thing says Bernie said at the debate
he wants a $15 minimum wage is it a
primary source when it's an uncited
Twitter image sent out by James Woods no
so go to Bernie's website and find it
now it happens that that that is
accurate Bernie does want a $15 minimum
wage then you look at the numbers well
$15 an hour times 40 hours a week times
52 weeks a year critically analysed it
does everyone work 40 hours in their job
no does everyone work 52 weeks in a year
no so there are holes there once you
critically analyze it Bernie wants free
health care and said raise taxes to 52%
on anyone making over $29,000 am I
looking at a primary source with
Bernie's tax tables no I'm not go to
Bernie's website find his actual
marginal tax tables and you will see
that if you earned $29,000 you're not in
the 52 percent marginal tax bracket you
need to earn ten million dollars per
year to get to Bernie's 52 percent
marginal tax bracket you can also simply
apply critical thinking and say does it
pass the sniff test that someone earning
29 grand a year would be paying 52
percent marginal tax rate and the answer
is of course no so a very quick analysis
of that meme with the with the sort of
paradigm of caps critically analysed
primary sources tells us we are looking
at non primary sources
it's an unsourced tweet from a
right-wing celebrity you are completely
lacking critical analysis if you simply
accept it and that's the only way that
you fall for it now if you want to look
at more detailed ways for protecting
yourself from disinformation propaganda
there are many strategies for keeping
emotions under control when you see
information how to corroborate it
evaluating whether conclusions that you
are being told follow from the premises
these actually follow from the premises
but you can google that google how to
protect yourself from persuasion
propaganda how to protect yourself from
disinformation there will be plenty of
reading but absent all of that always
refer to when you see that tweet when
you see that Facebook post from your
right-wing uncle when you see Trump say
it at a rally caps critically analyze
primary sources once you have identified
the primary sources and we will all be
much much better off as many of you know
I am super careful about where we
publish and distribute david pakman show
content it's a really important decision
that we make where do we want our
content to be we don't want to spread
ourselves too thin but we want to make
sure that we're taking advantage of good
platforms where our content could do
well and over the last couple of months
I've been testing publishing our content
to a platform called library that's lbr
why I've mentioned it once or twice
before and we are absolutely loving it
it's a fantastic platform where our
revenue as publishers does not depend on
some algorithm deciding whether an ad
should run before a video or not in fact
it's actually an ad-free platform where
our revenue is determined by the number
of people that watch our videos and also
by the tips that are left for us in
credits that are in platform credits
it's their own sort of currency so to
speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified sign up we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
David Pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit we'll get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about
it's going there's also a contest that
they're running whoever can refer the
most new users gets a huge reward which
would be a big big boost to us so check
it out link down in the video
description sign up let me know what you
think